hi everyone i'm alex jen and today i'm
going to be going through some
coordination exercises
this is a bit different from what i
usually do as it doesn't involve weapons
however you can apply these same
movements using clubs
before we start if you've been finding
these videos interesting please remember
to like share and subscribe
as this really helps the channel grow
anyway with that being said let's get
into it
[Music]
the exercises i'm going to be showing
you are based on some tai chi movements
however i actually learned these from
nick walser who's a part instructor
i'll put his details in the description
below as it's worth checking out his
content
so all these movements involve extended
arms rotating in front of the body
and behind and also both directions
when i combine both our movements
together there's four modes in total
based on timing and direction
i'll show each exercise separately and
then i'll explain how to link them all
together at the end of the video
with the first exercise we want both
arms extended moving a circle in front
of the body
they move together in parallel and we
can do this in both directions
key things to remember is to keep them
the same distance apart throughout the
rotation
and also make sure your arms are level
at the top and bottom and at the sides
all these four points are important with
all four exercises
next is anti-parallel crossing at the
sides arms move in opposite directions
with the cross points being right and
left
move your arms in opposite directions so
one goes up the other goes down
when they're facing opposite directions
turn from the hips
and bring them together at the opposite
side again this can be done both
directions
and repeat the process until it becomes
a fluid movement
now we move on to the other two modes
involving the rotation behind the body
starting with the arms extended out
opposite sides
they move together in parallel but in
split time this creates a windmill type
of motion
hands should always be pointing opposite
directions and your stance will need to
adjust slightly
to allow for extra hip rotation this
will enable
full circles on the back plane room you
can move both directions and sometimes
it might be easier to think of this
like swing forwards and backstroke then
when you're comfortable with this you
can smooth out your movement
the last mode i'll show is anti-parallel
but this time crossing at the top and
bottom
same hip rotation is required to get
behind your back this time your arms
move in opposite directions
the coordination for this movement can
be challenging so break it down
into the four key points top and bottom
the arms will pass
one in front one behind and at the sides
they should be level remember to train
both directions
and practice slowly to ensure that you
have correct movement
once you're able to form these moves you
can start linking them together each
mode links to two other modes depending
on where your hand positioning is
for example if i'm moving in parallel i
can switch to anti-parallel
at the top and bottom if in parallel my
arms are at the sides
i can switch to anti-parallel left and
right
experiment with the different modes and
have a go at joining the movements
together
take it slow remember the four key
points and options to move both
directions
[Music]
i hope you found these exercises useful
they should help with hip rotation
plane alignment and coordination all of
which i've covered in previous videos
if you have any questions leave them in
the comments below and remember to check
out my other videos as you might find
something of interest there
anyway until next time take care and
i'll see you soon
[Music]